[electronic music]
>> David Ebershoff: It's a great privilege
to publish Gary Shteyngart's
third novel. [crowd noises] He's really risen
to the top of the
literary ranks with this new book easily outshining
his
last two novels. What's truly remarkable about
Gary is
that he's accomplished so much while hiding
an unusual
secret.
>>Gary Shteyngart: I can't read.
[kissy noises]
[music]
>> Edmund White: He wants me to write a blurb.
I already got it worked
out in my mind. Super Sad thing is a dystopian
novel
about linear future. And the scary thing is
it's already
happening. He's our greatest satirist. But
he can also
write about real feelings like love.
>>Male Interviewer: What did you think of
the ending of the novel?
>> Edmund White: I haven't gotten that far.
Actually I've only read
just the beginning.
>>Edmund: Well, here's another homo wild.
>>Gary: I feel famous; homo famous.
>>Edmund: A famous homo
>> Gary: So pretty
>>Male Interviewer: He has this big teaching
position at Columbia.
>>Edmund: Columbia? They let him teach at
Columbia? Oh my God. Think of
our poor kids.
>>Maria Emmighausen: He's a huge inspiration.
He came from nowhere. And
he's, you know, still kind of nowhere. But
he knows how
to work the literary world.
>>Male Interviewer: What was your favorite
class of him?
>> Maria: I guess his seminar on how to behave
at a Paris review
party.
>> Gary: Well, you know I do so much prefer
early Ian McEwan to late Ian McEwan Ahem,
ahem.
>> Students together: Well, I do so much prefer
the early Ian McEwan to late Ian McEwan.
>>Gary: Not so Jewish
>>Male student: Mu-ha-ha
>>Gary: No. No, no. Ahem, ahem. It has to
come from deep in heart. Not
from throat. James Franco, please teach this.
>> James Franco: Ahem, ahem
>>Gary: See this this is real author. Less
is more.
>>James Franco: Actually haven't read his
new book -- Sad True --
whatever. But, you know, I don't think he
actually wants
me to read it. I don't think reading is really
his
thing.
>> Gary: The. The. The girl.
>> James Franco: Yeah, we got that one.
>> Gary: So.
>> Gary: It's never going to be easy. Because
this is Socratic
method. This is, you know, inquiry.
>> James Franco: What he really wants to do
is cash in on the whole
Hollywood vampire thing. Like, but, you know,
we're
going to do like this werewolf thing but they're
not
wolves. They're bears. Like were-bears.
>>Gary: Grrrrrrrr
>>David Ebershoff: Working with Gary has been
a singular experience.
>> Male Interviewer: Because of his voice
and his style?
>> David Ebershoff: No. Because he demands
his advance be paid entirely in smoked meat,
pickled tomatoes, and three recently graduated
débutantes from Mount Holyoke.
>> Mary Gaitskill: Not that I'm bitter because
I love Gary.
>> Gary: Women can be writer, too, huh.
>> Mary Gaitskill: We try.
>> Gary: You try.
>> Mary Gaitskill: No. Our brain, you know,
we just try so hard to
separate our brain from, you know.
>>Gary: Yes.
>>Mary Gaitskill: But let's face it. The only
reason Gary gets
published is because he's so good looking.
>>Jeffrey Eugenides: At some point in college
he took some mushrooms. Some
kind of hallucinogenic and had a vision that
he was
actually an immigrant from Russia. So he began
writing
from that point of view, you know, imagine
what his
parents would be like. Started having an accent.
>> Gary: Such a good boy. Oh. Eat. Eat turkey.
>> Edmund: You know what you're like? You're
like lady with a lap dog from the Chekhov
story
>>Gary: Who?
>> Edmund: Chekhov story.
>>Gary: Guy from Star Trek writes stories?
>> Jeffrey: Gary has managed to escape the
anxiety of influence by
the sheer fact that he has never read a word.
>> Male Interviewer: That must be very empowering.
>>Jeffrey: I would think so. I really admire
that state of pure
ignorance.
>> Gary: You try to escape.
>> Gary: Oh, no. Oh, yeah. Gary.
>>McInerney: Gary
>>Gary: McInerney. Thanks God you're here.
I'm having babe
problems.
>>McInerney: Oh. Don't worry. This happens
to me all the time.
>>Gary: It does?
>> McInerney: Vassar or Mount Holyoke?
>>Gary: Mount Goalie-yoke
>>McInerney: Hey, girls meet the author. With
his roots deep in Russian
literature Shteyngart has become an important
and
indispensable American writer. Super Sad True
Sexy Love Story
shows him in his smart, soulful and hilarious
best.
[music]
[Applause].
>>Gary: How do you top that.
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: Hi everyone. Thank you
for coming to today's authors
at Google talk. I'm really excited to have
Gary
Shteyngart here with us today. Gary is local
to New York,
I believe. He's local New York writer. He's
a modern
day satirist. He's one of the funniest writers
around in
my opinion. He's also the author of Absurdistan,
The
Russian Débutante's Handbook, and most recently,
Super Sad True
Love Story. He has made -- his books have
made pretty
much every best of list -- year end wrap up
best of list.
New York times, Washington post. I could go
on and on.
>> Gary: Please do.
>> Female Presenter: And yeah, [giggles] the
New Yorker actually named him one of the
20 under 40 luminary fiction writers. So I'm
really
excited to have him here today.
>> Gary: It's great to be here.
>> Female Presenter: So as people were walking
in, we were showing his book
trailer for Super Sad True Love Story. And
where did you
come up with that idea? Is that a common thing?
I've
never actually seen a book trailer before.
>>Gary: [laughing] I'm proud to say we pioneered
the comical book trailer
with this thing. James Franco was a student
of mine at
the Columbian University. And one day I was
at Yaddo
which is a writer's colony up state. And I
was drunk out
of my mind. And the two ideas sort of floated
in my
head. One was illiteracy and the other was
James Franco [laughter] and we
sort of combined the two and I woke up in
the morning I
started writing the script to this thing.
And then it
was just a matter of getting everyone else
to
participate. And writers are great hams. Every
writer
wants to be out there. I didn't have to ask
twice. We
get Salman but he was out unfortunately.
[laughter]
>>Female Presenter: [giggling] And is that
a prerequisite -- is that part of your
writing process -- you have to be hopelessly
drunk to get
anything done.
>> Gary: It's part of my heritage. [laughs]
>>Female Presenter: All right
>>Gary: Important to be inebriated to get
the juices floating.
>> Female Presenter: Stay true to your roots.
>>Gary: Stay true, yeah
>>Female Presenter: So I think several people
in this audience have
actually already read your book
>>Gary: Wow. That's impressive.
>>Female Presenter: And we actually have the
Extreme
Reading Book Club joining us from Mountain
View on VC.
You can't see them. They're there; they're
out there.
>>Gary: Really? Good Lord. You guys are high-tech.
>>Female Presenter: [giggling] We are. We
are Google. So if -- for those of you --
in the audience who actually haven't read
the book yet,
do you want to talk about it a little bit
-- give a brief
synopsis.
>> Gary: Very briefly, it's a a love story
set in the very near
future when a completely illiterate America
is about to
fall apart so next Tuesday or so. And it can.
The
previous books I've written have all been
about
immigrants. Usually immigrants from Russia
which is
where I was born. But in this case, the characters
--
there's two characters – Lenny, who's of
Russian background, and Eunice, who's of Korean
American background. And the real difference
between the
two is that Lenny is an immigrant from the
analog age.
He still reads books. He still cares about
literature very much and
Eunice is purely digital. All she does is
shop online.
In this future there is no journalism. There's
no
reading. All that's left is this app-arat
which is worn
as a pendant around your neck. And what it
does is it
automatically ranks you wherever you go. So
let's say I
walk into a bar in Chelsea, I'm immediately
the 7th
ugliest man in the room [laughter] but I have
the third best credit
rating or something like that. So you're constantly
being judged wherever you go. And everyone
tries to
improve their ratings. In fact, when Lenny
starts going
out with Eunice who's really cute, his rankings
go up a
lot.
>>Female Presenter: Yeah, so it's all pretty
relative. I mean, you walk
into a room and depending on how many people
are in the
room, you're stack ranked against them.
>> Gary: Yeah, I mean, that sort of happens
without digital
technology too, but this is just a nice way
to know
exactly where you are. [laughter] Stupid things.
>>Female Presenter Yeah. So I mean, there's
a lot going on here. I
think, you know, we've got the global teen's
account.
We've got the apparats. The fashion. And even
the
language. I mean you have a lot of different
acronyms. You have
JBF for one. [giggles]
>> Gary: JBF -- it means just butt fucking
you. I knew a very
young person who kept saying J/K, which means
just
kidding, I guess.
>>Female Presenter: yeah
>>Gary: So I thought where would this go in
the
future. And it would be just butt fucking
you.
>>Female Presenter: And then you have things
like onion jeans it's kind of
like taking what is --, you know, just like
with fashion
or what is, I guess, soft porn today could
it be completely
normal and mainstream tomorrow.
>> Gary: Mainstream. Well, what shocked me
about onion skin jeans which are basically
completely transparent jeans women wear in
the future is
that two months after this book came out the
New York
times did an article about the fashion show
in Paris and
they had completely transparent jeans.
>>Female Presenter: Of course, yeah.
>>Gary: So I'm kind of
the Nostradamus of two months from now. [laughter]
And that's the
problem with writing fiction these days is
because the
future -- and you guys are creating it obviously
-- it
moves so fast there's no way one can write
about the
present. There's no present left. You know,
I started
this book in 2006. If I had been writing about
what the
characters would have be about doing they
would have been
on MySpace or something.
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: You also write about
the collapsing economy. And you
write about the protests going on. And I'm
sure you've
gotten this question a lot. But, you know,
I'm sure
people are coming with you. You predicted
Occupy Wall
Street, the financial collapse. And I heard
that you
started writing this book in 2006.
>>Gary: Right. I started in 2006. I'm from
a failed
empire -- the Soviet Union, so I have a really
good sense
of when things are going downhill. [laughter]
In fact, every empire
I come to collapses. The State Department
is trying to
send me to China.
>> Female Presenter: Maybe it's you. Yeah.
Maybe it's wherever you go, yeah.
>> Maybe it's me. It's just me. So when I
started writing it, the idea
I had was that Lehman brothers and the big
banks would
collapse and the auto industry would collapse.
By 2008,
all those things had happened. [chuckles]
So I had to make things
worse and worse and in Super Sad it gets bad
enough that
basically the whole country gets bought out
by a
Norwegian hedge-fund in China. So.
>> Female Presenter: Did you think it would
happen so soon.
>> Gary: I don't think it would happen so
soon. I honestly
thought it would I had two or three years
before these
things would come to pass. But that's not
how it works
these days, you know.
>>Female Presenter: yeah
>> Gary: You know, back in the day, novelists
-- I'm no Tolstoy,
but when Tolstoy was writing War and Peace
in 1862 a
horse was a horse and a carriage was a carriage.
He
could have been writing about 1812, the Napoleonic
wars,
and still, you know, life had changed obviously.
The
Industrial Revolution had started, but so
many things were the same.
These days, even two or three years makes
a huge
difference. Tolstoy didn't have to worry about
the
latest killer app, you know.
>> Female Presenter: Yeah. With, I think,
for your two previous novels, you
had written Russian Jewish characters and
they're both
male protagonists. And then in this book,
I think, it's your
first love story. It's also your first female
-- one of the
lead characters. With Eunice Park. So how
did you
decide to write a love story this time.
>> Gary: Well, I thought that it would be.
One of my
inspirations was Orwell's 1984. The two big
novels – the great
dystopian novels – obviously are Huxley's
Brave New World and
Orwell's 1984. In some ways, as a novel of
ideas, Brave New World is
a lot more fascinating. He predicted so many
things. SOMA which is our Valium mixed with
Klonopin
mixed with I don't know what. So much of what
Huxley
predicted came true. Orwell really took Stalin's
Russia and Stalin's Soviet
Union and took it to 11. But I remember 1984
a lot more
than I do Brave New World because of the characters
--
because it's a love story. Winston and Julia
are in love
and there's this society trying to pry them
apart. What
I thought I would do for this book -- they're
in love,
but there's no need for a big brother because
everyone is
sort of deputized to chronicle their lives
at all times.
The government doesn't need to spy into your
bedroom ,
because everyone in this society constantly
updates where they
are, what they're doing, who they're sleeping
with, what
kind of sex they enjoy. And everywhere you
go these
streams are everywhere around you. I sort
of thought
what would an Orwellian future look like without
the
government actually controlling things.
>>Female Presenter: And what made you decide
to write this from a diary
and personal memoir kind of standpoint. So
you have
Lenny writing the diary and Eunice -- it's
kind of like
through her global teens account which is
a mix of e-mail
and chat and Twitter type messages.
>> Gary: Yeah, in fact one of the challenges
was because
Eunice -- well Eunice is one of the smartest
people in
this future, because she can still write in
complete
sentences which is very rare. Lenny calls
her 'my
reluctant sentence monger' because she has
a subject and a
predicate, usually, and he's really impressed
by that. Again it's an
illiterate future, I have to make these characters
somewhat
literate so that the literate audiences in
Brooklyn and
Seattle can enjoy this book. [laughter] And
that was tough to do, to
sort of walk that fine line between her being
talking in
this -- what's one acronym. TIMATOV, I think
I'm about to
openly vomit. [laughter] Between that and
trying to write a
literary novel -- well, there are a lot of
pitfalls.
>> Female Presenter: And what was it like
getting inside her head
considering you've written male characters
before.
>> Gary: So male, so male. [laughter] It was
great. It was actually very
very liberating to be inside the mind of somebody
who's
from a different mind set than my own; who's
from a
different gender obviously, different race,
different --
the only thing that was -- that felt familiar
to me in
writing the Eunice character was that she
was a daughter
of immigrants with all the nightmarish stuff
that come packaged
with the crazy parents insisting you should
do this and
that. Even in this future where law isn't
much of a
career choice. There's only three careers
left -- media,
retail and credit; those are the three careers.
But her mother is still pushing her
to take the LSAT hoping she'd go to law school.
[laughs]
>>Female Presenter: That sounds like Korean.
I'm Korean. I'm from southern California.
I'm you know
it's funny.
>> Gary: Well then. You're the perfect demographic.
>> Female Presenter: This sounds really, really
familiar. I mean, aside
from the abusive father. I didn't have an
abusive
father.
>> Gary: You missed out on a lot. Those are
the best. They're
really great motivators. [laughter]
>>Female Presenter: Oh well. [giggles] That's
too bad.
>>Gary: Succeed or else. It's really
funny when I do readings often and couples
come up to
me -- "I'm Lenny." And the woman is like,
""and I'm
Eunice."
[laughter]
>>Gary: And the Lenny says all she does is
shop online all day
long.
[laughs]
>> Gary: And she's like, "yeah, that's what
I do."
>>Female Presenter: yeah, that's me
>>Gary: I'm like
you guys are the best. Thank you for existing.
>> Female Presenter: And yeah, another book
I read recently was My Korean
Deli by Ben Ryder Howe.
>>Gary: I want to see that; I want to read
that. [laughs] I want to stream that.
>> Female Presenter: I think that's interesting
because the two books I
happen to read about the Korean American culture
were written by
non-Koreans. I thought that was interesting.
I think
you've kind of toed the line from writing
from what you
know, writing part of your experience and
then also kind
of examining another culture. What did you
find to be
the benefit of either approach?
>> Well, I went to Stuyvesant so Koreans [laughs]
I have known all
my life. In fact, most of my best friends
were Koreans
growing up because of Stuyvesant. And then
my mentor was
Chang-Rae Lee, the Korean American author.
So this isn't a culture I
approach with sort of -- it's one I know well
and I love
Korea, I love Seoul. I think it's one of the
most
fascinating cities. I like the confluence
between Soviet Jewish
families and Korean American families. I think
there's a lot of
similarity in that both ethnic groups have
experienced a
horrific 20th century. Both are small groups
within a
larger context. The Soviet Jews were a small
oppressed
group within Russia, Ukraine and other places.
Korea was a
once colonized group surrounded by Japan,
parents who are
completely obsessed about academic achievement.
I mean,
many ethnic groups obviously share that as
well but I think here
there's a particular brand of insanity and
the love of
cabbage is very important to both people.
>>Female Presenter: Yeah, yes, absolutely
>>Gary: Although I have to say the
Koreans do a much better job by adding spice
to it.
>> Female Presenter: Yeah, kimchi. It's pretty
good. I can't lie.
>>Gary: Kimchi is not bad.
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
You've created an incredibly vivid world with
this novel.
And is there anything that you weren't able
to include
that you had dreamed of.
>> Gary: Sure. Well, I mean, the book kind
of became an
obsession for me because I was starting to
be sucked into
the technological world. I mean, starting
with Google
really. I used to do a lot of my research
by going to
the Slavic section of the New York public
library in
forty-second street where I would catch the
most exotic Uzbek Flus
and whatnot.
[laughter]
>> Gary: But then when Google came along,
all that stopped. I
never left my home. I stopped socializing.
[laughter] And so, each
new layer of the technology -- the iTelephone
-- the
Facebook, follow me on Facebook and Twitter.
>> Female Presenter: Yeah, I noticed you had
accounts for both.
>> Gary: I started Twitter two months ago.
Now I never leave
home. [laughter] So, you know, I notice that
this technology was
taking over my life. It was also making it
difficult to
concentrate on long form texts -- like books.
It's very
difficult for me to read a 500-page book..
>>Female Presenter: Yeah
>>Gary: I constantly get books to blurb. I
don't even
read them anymore. I just blurb them. It's
just too hard.
>> Female Presenter: Are they turning smelly?
Have you noticed that.
>> Gary: The smell is the best part; I love
it. Books are like fine wines age very
well. And I have a lot of books from the Soviet
Union
growing up and they smell terrific. Much better
than
many of the people who sold them to us. So
you know I
notice that my life was changing. Although
I'm not
exactly in the, you know, what do they call
-- the early
adapters -- I'm always the last adapter. Even
so I
noticed my life was becoming more online.
That I was
concerned with things that were very different
than
before. Before I just basically wanted to
find space and
time to write. But now I was sort of writing
all the
time, because the moment I walk out of anything
I start
typing on my iPhone. And that makes writing
a book --
you're thinking, "well, I write all day long.
How is
this different?" It also makes-- since books
are going
digital -- it makes a different dynamic for
a book. It's
no longer an object, and to some of us, a
sacred object. It's now a text file. One of
the many text files that's being sent across
the
Internet. So coping with this stuff has been
very
difficult for me. I think most writers fall
into my
camp. There are some writers that are very
excited about
the technology. But I haven't seen -- what's
interesting
to me also is I teach at Columbia at the MFA
level and
everyone wants to be a writer there, obviously.
And I
noticed that a lot of my students do not have
-- the
technology is often missing from their work.
So they'll
have a story where people, you know, people
are out on a
date and they're not texting their friends
about how the
date is going. To me, that's surprising because
it seems --
>> Female Presenter: Are they disconnecting?
Are they purposely not
getting smart phones.
>>Gary: I think they have this technology
that there's
something sweet about this. They know how
endangered
their mode of communication is by the new
technology that
they almost want to go back to the kind of
novel where
people would run to a pay phone and put in
25 cents and
dial their mother which never happens.
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: There is a recent article
in the times by Pico Iyer about the
joy of quiet. Did you see that? Just about
how with all
this technology around us, how do we disconnect.
How do
we find those moments of quiet? And even at
Google, we have a training class
called "managing your energy." It's like sleep
more, you
know, make sure you leave -- you close your
laptop and
don't check your phone when you roll over
and look at it
first thing in the morning.
>> Gary: First thing in the morning, I wake
up three in the
middle of the night and look at it. It's horrible.
The
only thing I've found I have a little cabin
up state and I go up
there. AT&T will not connect my itelephone
up there. Thanks
to our country's crummy infrastructure, I'm
able to
actually [laughter] -- this wouldn't happen
in Korea, believe me.
I'm able to escape the constantly being connected
by
doing that.
>>Female Presenter: Okay. Has your writing
process changed like before
and after the technology entered it?
>> Gary: It's gotten worse. I'm -- as I said
-- I'm not able.
A lot of writing is also reading. A lot of
writing is
saying for three hours a day I'm not going
to do anything
but read a book. And that book -- whatever
it is you're
reading. It could be the classics. It could
be
something by one of the brilliant young authors
we have
these days. You interact with
it. It becomes part of you. Reading is basically
saying I'm going to leave my own
personality for awhile and enter the consciousness
of
another human being. That's actually pretty
advanced
technology for being 500 years old or however
old the
book is. And that's becoming increasingly
hard to do to develop
that sense of empathy. Because everything
is screaming
for my attention. It's like I'm at a party
where
everyone is saying “hey look at me; look
at me; look at me.” So my
writing is hampered by my lack of sustained
reading. And
that's why going up state and turning -- well
I can't
turn it off. It just doesn't work. I have
to go on this
mountain and on top of a bear on top of a
tree to get any
kind of signal. [laughter] You know. So that's
been very
instrumental to helping me read which helps
me write.
>> Female Presenter: How often do you do that.
>> Gary: I spent most of the fall up there.
I teach one
semester at Columbia so this --. The next
four months are going to
be here in New York. And that's -- not much
is going to
get done -- a lot of distractions. And the
iPhone and
New York together -- why live?
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: So I figured we could
probably start taking some
audience questions. So feel free to come up
to the mics
if you have any.
>> Gary: I'll answer anything.
>>Male #1: Hi. Thanks for coming to talk to
us. Really
appreciate it. I love the book. I bought three
copies
so you're welcome.
[laughter]
>>Gary: I'm eating steak because of you
>> Male #1: And so, after I read it, I was
like it's a really brilliant
book. I went to Amazon. Let's see what other
people had
to say about it. I think what surprised me
is the comments
often fell into two camps. One camp was "this
book is
totally unrealistic." I was like kind of misses
the
point. [laughter] And then there was another
camp which thought it
was supposed to be science fiction. It wasn't
future
looking enough which I also thought missed
the point. I
was kind of wondering if you anticipated either
of those
things happening and what your reaction to
that was.
>> Gary: Sure, that's a good question. You
know, I grew up on science fiction completely.
Asimov's Science Fiction magazine, that was
my big nerd pleasure
growing up. And I was much more in tune with
technology
than I am right now. I had the first Commodore
64 on the block and the Atari 2600.
Many of you don't even know what this is,
right? The Commodore 64, it was
a big deal back then and the Apple 2E all
this crap. So
I loved -- you know, I loved the idea of science
fiction.
On the other hand, at this point I know nothing
about
science. You know, my Stuyvesant four years
notwithstanding. So I had to hire an intern
who is very
attractive. People call him the man-tern.
All my female
friends fell in love with him. And the man-tern
had a science background, [laughter] taught
me all this stuff how a cell becomes a law,
you know. But
the first version I had of this book was much
more
science fictiony than it is now. And my editor
at Random
House, who you saw on the screen, said you
don't really
know much about science do you? And it shows.
But you do know about heartbreak so write
about that.
And so,
the book became gradually less science fictiony.
So, and
I'm glad that happened, because in a way it's
writing to
my strengths. But I knew that this book would
be a little
strange to position. Because there is a so-called
ghetto
called literary fiction. And once your book
is slotted
into that, you're not going to get any sales
at Costco.
It's shocking that this made the times best
seller list. You
know you really are making your audience.
Seattle,
Brooklyn, Portland, parts of Boston. The research
triangle. [laughter] You know, you're limiting
yourself. So, but
this is a strange kind of hybrid animal because
it does
have some science fictiony elements. And a
lot of
authors have been playing around with this
idea of genre. Jonathan Lethem's Motherless
Brooklyn is a good example.
It's a detective story but it falls more within
the realm
of literary fiction. The problem with literary
fiction -- don't quote me on this except this
is on
YouTube or whatever -- I find a lot of it
quite dull. I mean it's
great to write about one's parents divorcing
in west
Chester. It's an important topic. [laughter]
And it's great to do
it in some experimental new way. You know
where it's
narrated by the cat, let's say. [laughter]
But I do find that genres
like science fiction and mystery are excellent
in terms
of getting something new across. Thank you
so much.
>>Gary: And thanks for buying all them books
-- damn. Learn
by his example.
[laughter]
>> Female #1: I also bought your book but
it's on my Kindle. I don't
know if that's.
>> Gary: Ooh -- snap.
[laughter]
>>Female #1: I was wondering -- one of the
things I've been
thinking about after reading your book I find
that with
my gadgets, I actually read a lot more fiction
because I
can download like your New Yorker stories
onto my phone
and read them on the subway and all that.
I'm wondering
if you think that this -- have your books
about people
pulling away from reading. If we're caught
sort of in
this zone where our devices are going to become
easier
for us and the industry is going to adapt
so we're more
connected to reading over time or is this
just downhill.
>> Gary: Well, the industry is struggling
to adapt quite a bit.
I'll give you an example. 2006 when
Absurdistan, my previous book came out, one
percent of all sales were
electronic. This book -- it's about 35 percent.
I
predict the next book will be 50 percent or
more. I'm
not going to stand in front of this incoming
train and
say I'm going to stop this. Because this is
going to
happen. There's no question about that. At
least half
of all books, if not more, if not the majority
are going to be read on
devices. So I'm really happy when
people read it on their devices. It's interesting
how
many people come up to me with their iPads
to sign. I sign their iPads. [laughter] They
want me to sign their iPads which I find to
be adorable.
A lot of the Eunices have them and the Lennys
will have
the old books. And I'm fine with both people
you know.
Now, this is my professor mode -- scientists
show that
reading comprehension off a screen is about
9 to 10 percent less than
off the printed page. Why is that I don't
know. Is it
all the distractions a screen presents. I
haven't read using
a Kindle but I do read the New York Times
on my iPhone.
I find that a lot more distracting obviously
than --
sometimes when I get the actual paper, I realize
just how
deeply I read it. Sunday spent with the Times
is really
an immersive experience. I read sections – I
would never even think of --
automobile -- I don't even know how to drive
[laughter] yet there's
something fascinating about those, you know,
the
articles. So and the other thing that I like
about books
is that they are -- and this is from a commercial
standpoint, too, is they're also advertisements
for
themselves. I would love for an iPad or Kindle
or whatever to
have a back screen where they show the title
or a picture of the book you're
reading -- the cover because that also tells
other people
this is what I'm reading. I used to ride the
subway all
the time as a kid trying to get women to notice
me by
reading Ulysses over and over and over.
[laughter]
>>Gary: Hey. You know?
>>Female Presenter: Yeah, I was going to say
actually I bought your book
because I saw so many people on the subway
reading it
which is interesting.
>>Gary: If there's a Kindle you don't know
it's out there.
Also, this is a great way to get to know somebody.
Let's
say you're out on a date and you're at somebody
cease
house and the bookshelf is all Glenn Beck,
so you're like, "oh,
this is going to be an interesting relationship."
Sarah
Palin's new bio. Hmm. [laughter]
>> Male #2: Go see the Google digital library.
>> Gary: Yeah, I will. I'll take a look at
it. What I'm
saying is those bookshelves show a lot. I
guess there's
a way to do it in the future where we can
walk in and there's a giant screen
that says I'm a Beck lover. So that's my word.
[laughter]
>> Female #1: And what about sites like good
reads. I find most of
my new books that I read and new authors because
of
online connections. People post about it on
Facebook or
there are social networks for it or just reading
blogs
about.
>> Gary: I think that's wonderful. I think
it's wonderful that
there's so many sites that unite readers.
What I'm
worried about the is there's been a cost.
There's a trade off
here. The cost has been the death of a lot
of book
reviews. This country used to have -- right
now we have
basically the New York Times book section
and I think
that's it. I think the LA Times has been folded
into
entertainment whatever that is. Washington
Post also.
The Chicago papers are done for. You know,
this country
used to support dozens of book sections. Not
just that
but the New York Times Book Review -- love
it or hate
it -- used to be about 80 pages long. Now
it's about 25
pages long. I used to review books when I
became a
writer. It's not really done anymore. Nobody
gets paid
for it. There's very few serious book reviewers.
There's Kakutani at the New York Times; James
Woods at The New Yorker. Talk about
the culture, the cult of the amateur and a
lot of the
amateurs are terrific. But there's really
been a huge fall
off in how people -- people used to buy their
newspaper and go
to the book section. Oh this is what so and
so, who is not just
somebody who reads three or four books a year
and is now writing, I like
science fiction I like this but somebody who
for a living
reads hundreds of books a year and has a good
opinion
about things or at least an informed opinion
one that you
can completely disagree with. So that's the
trade off that bothers me.
All these things like GoodReads existed, if
there was a healthy
good culture of criticism and review in this
country, I'd
be the happiest doe in the forest. [laughter]
But sadly, the
Internet has eaten away at those things by
destroying --
by the fact there's no ad revenues from print
and hence
that part has fallen apart.
>>Female #1: Thanks.
>> Male #3: Hey Gary thanks for coming. Enjoyed
your book. I
only bought one copy.
>> Gary: Oh, damn you.
>>Male #3: Can you talk a little bit about,
there was one passage in the
book that I thought was interesting, about
how our generation like maybe under 30 or
wants to be thought of as special as each
person. Just
sort of your thinking behind that. Is that
something you
see as a pervasive issue.
>> Gary: Well, it's fascinating. The immigrants
were brought
up to be very humble. At the same time you
had to be
very ambitious, but you're also steeped in
humility. I
remember PTA in Hebrew school when I was a
kid. My
father came to see the teacher and she said,
"I hear that
Gary reads Tolstoy in the original Russian.
My dad said, “no, just Chekhov. Ptui. He's
not smart”. [laughter] But now
it's the very opposite. It's parents saying,
“oh my kid. He's
going to work for Google some day. He's brilliant”.
I
think there's -- and I think this is the social
media
where -- I mean, everyone is an author today
in a sense.
We're all writing a book. People are reading
less and
less, but more and more people want to become
writers at
places like the Columbia we have so many applications.
And this is a terrible economy and it's fairly
costly to
go to a school like that. And people want
to become
writers quite desperately.
And the other visual artists as well, film.
You know,
everybody wants to express themselves. We
have this
incredible culture of self-expression. I think
that's fine,
but if everyone is special then who gets to
just read the
special people? You know what I'm saying?
What if there
was more of a balance and there were maybe
some fewer
writers but some more readers. Wouldn't that
be
interesting for our society as well? And I
think maybe
it's part of the culture of things like video
games as
well. When you're playing a video game, you're
not
passively watching something . You're in the
middle of
the action. You're the hero. And how do you
do that
with a book? When you open the book, you're
not the
hero. There's somebody else. And that is a
little hard to adapt
to. And I'm finding that as someone who twitters
and
Facebooks my brains outed, you know, I find
it difficult
sometimes to say, "just calm down and just
be passive and
read something or engage in media that you
didn't
create yourself.
>> Male #3: Do you think that's more of American
problem or --
because there seems to be difference in the
way you treat
the Asia countries and their ascendancy versus
America in
the near future.
>> Gary: Yeah, I don't think there's a great
culture of
specialness in many Asian cultures. Maybe
you would
disagree. There's a collective unit that's
very
important that's not as important in America
which is the
most individualistic country that the world
has ever
known. And that individualism has worked wonders
for
us -- has allowed us to create some really
incredible
products and some really incredible ideas.
On the other
hand, the highway to the JFK airport could
be found in Burkina Faso, at this point.
Flying from Newark Airport to Beijing Capital
Airport is a very depressing
experience. You know you see where the future
belongs
to. And that required the effort of a lot
of people to
put together the world's greatest terminal.
So I don't
know. You know, in terms of the economy I
also worry
about this. I worry are we going to be a nation
of Apple
and Google and some really cutting edge, creative
energy
that employs wonderful amount of people but
a small
amount of people. You know, what's going to
happen to
the majority of this country that doesn't
have this
really incredible education and it used to
be that in
America, you know, even if you were -- even
if you just
finished high school and you wanted to find
a job, you
could get a job at a factory with health care
and with
better opportunities for your children. And
the book the
world of Super Sad True Love Story, that's
gone. None of that
exists anymore. There's credit, retail and
media and those are the
only three industries that are left in the
country and they employ people
on the coasts who consider themselves to be
high net worth
individuals and the rest are just left as
sort of -- as a
failed part of the country. I think we're
seeing that
happen already. And it's getting a little
sad for me.
Super sad. [laughter]
>> Male #4: Thanks again for coming. I want
to preface this by
saying I've only read an excerpt of the book
in New York.
I haven't read the whole book yet.
>>Gary: It gets much worse. It goes downhill
from there.
[laughter]
>> Male #4: Fair enough. I am looking forward
to reading it. My understanding of the book's
overall
genre might be a little clouded based on not
having read
all of it but you allude to 1984 as being
something of an
influence in the whole genre of dystopian
novels it goes
back quite a bit. They tend to be fairly earnest.
They
try to, you know, get across a fairly important
message.
And my understanding is that there's certainly
this
dystopian elements but there's also quite
a bit of satire,
youth culture, or illiteracy that sort of
thing. In your
novel how do you see those two kind of genres
coming
together. Dystopian and satire. It's not something
you
see very much of.
>>Gary: For a reason.
>> Male #4: I happen to -- I think George
Saunders for instance I
think does it quite well.
>>Gary: Amazing.
>>Male #4: It's very powerful when done well.
I'm kind of
curious what made you combine the two.
>> Gary: Thank you that's a good question.
I think, you know,
trying to sell a publisher I'm going to write
a dystopian
comic love story between two immigrants. They're
like
okay [laughs] we'll put out a print run of
eight copies. [laughter] You
mention Saunders. I'm one of the few people
that works
in his genre. I love his work. I'm always
paired with
him. I've done 100 readings with him in the
New York
festival alone. We're considered the two people
crazy
enough to work in this very strange build
your own genre
right there. I think of Jonathan Swift. I
think his
satire was really hilarious. There's a great
Russian
tradition of satire. Russia, as a perpetually
failed
state, engendered some really funny humor.
Gogol, one
of my premier Russian writers was my favorites.
The story that
really got me started as a writer was called
“The Nose”. And it's about a
nose that jumps off the face of a official
in 19th
century St. Petersburg and takes on a life
of his own and
the nose puts on a uniform and a tri-cornered
hat and
starts walking around St. Petersburg and wooing
women and
going to church and stuff like that. And it's
about 15
pages, but it captures Russia more eloquently
than the
novels that are thousands of pages long. So
inspirations
like that. And then, also the sort of Soviet
Jewish
humor that I have. I would call it humor from
the edge
of the grave, the humor of living in a country
that doesn't
provide very much opportunities for joy but
at the same
time trying to create your own joy by taking
the
dystopian elements around you and mercilessly
making fun
of them. This book was actual harder to write
than
Absurdistan and the Russian Débutante's Handbook
, because
those two previous novels were about the collapse
of the
Soviet Union in a way. In this, you know,
I was never a
great patriot of any country, when I was writing
this I
was thinking, "wow, I always take America
for granted and
if bad things happen to it, it happens to
me as well.
It's different when it's not just some Absurdistan
on
fire. It's different when it's your local
Duane Reade on
fire. And that made me very sad when I wrote
this.
>> Male #4: Thank you.
>> Male #5: I really loved your book. It was
wonderful. I just
love your book. And I want -- you said I could
ask
anything. How old were you when you came here?
>> Gary: That's a really private question.
[laughter] 7 years old.
>> Male #5: 7 years old.
>>Gary: School year 1979.
>> Male #5: So you don't really have an accent.
>>Gary: No, I speak real good. I had an accent
growing up but
I would practice in front of the mirror. I
would say
attic and I would say addict. Because my parents
only
spoke Russian in the house. A lot of Russian
immigrants
do that sort of thing. Are we going to speak
English and
then our child will speak their mother tongue
or should
we speak the original language in which case
we won't
learn any English but our child will have
their mother
tongue. So I'm glad they kept Russian.
>> Male #5: So you're fluent in Russian.
>> Gary: Pretty fluent.
>> Male #5: And where is that country house.
>> Gary: It's around Hudson, New York. Feel
free to come up and
stalk away. [laughter] I'm so lonely I don't
know how to drive to
the grocery store.
>> Male #5: Just so nice to have you here.
What else? [laughter] I love --
you know, there's so many things I'll never
forget about
that book like the Staten Island is the hip
new place. I
just love it. I love all the prices are geared
to the Yuan. Terrific, terrific hilarious.
That's all I wanted, anyway.
>> Gary: That's very sweet. This is the kind
of question I
enjoy because it makes me look good.
>>Male #5: Where do you live?
[laughter]
>>Gary: 347 19th street, apartment 3G. Just
come on by. Just
hanging out all day long.
>> Female Presenter: What are you working
on now.
>> Gary: Well, I'm writing a memoir, because
I'm 39 and
Russians live till 56 -- the men on average.
>> Female Presenter: So you only have one
more year to be on that 20 under
40 list.
>> Gary: Yeah, I'm like the grandfather of
that list. So sad.
>> Gary: Time flies. So a memoir which entailed
a lot of
interesting stuff. I had to go to Russia with
my
parents. I go back every year but they haven't
been back in about thirty
years. I drag them to see their old haunts.
>> Female Presenter: Did they want to go?
>> Gary: Not really, but it was cute. They
were -- they
visited all the grave sites. That's what you
do. You
visit all the ancestors. Oh, and I'm working
on an HBO
kind of project. Like every other author I
want to do a
project I guess about Queens is what I'm looking
at.
>> Female Presenter: Is it a mini series.
>> Gary: Not like a fiction series because
what's happened is
so much of fiction has really moved to the
screen -- to
the small screen, not the big screen -- a
lot of
writers -- well, you look at shows like the
Sopranos and
the Wire. The Wire is written by writers like
Richard Price,
excellent novelist. And things like the Sopranos
and the
Wire almost feel like a novel. They have this
incredible range
and scope and they last 58 hours which is
how long it
takes the average North American to read a
pamphlet. [laughter] So
they're exciting. A lot of people walk home.
You work
hard. You have a white-collar job. You come
home. The last thing you
want to do is read 400-page text. But things
like the
Wire and Soprano allow you to enjoy the narrative
energy
narrative momentum on the screen without having
to read.
>>Female Presenter: Yeah.
>>Male #6: Hi. Just on that last point and
I think you've raised
a couple other times the difficulty of getting
people to
actually read literature. Do you think there's
possibility of some of the new Internet services
like
Twitter, FourSquare or Facebook, or whatever
to actually be a vehicle
for literature?
>> Gary: Well, you know, one's publicist says
you must be on
those things to even live anymore in order
to sell a book. I had to make a film
to sell a book. In fact two films. I did another
one
with Paul Giamatti. Very important. All these
different
ways are – it's, you used to be able -- you
write a decent
book, you get good reviews and people would
buy hundreds
of thousands of copies. Now to sell those
hundreds of
thousands of copies you have to create -- you
have to be
on every social media imaginable. If I'm doing
a reading
in Camden, New Jersey -- before the intertube,
five people
would show up. Now I post on Facebook and
Twitter 100
more people would show up. Which is nice.
You have to
do -- you have to promote the book face to
face
everywhere you can. Because a lot of the NPR
outlets no
longer do -- have the authors. You'll still
can get on
the national ones but it used to be you'd
go to a place like
Denver and there'd be five NPRs waiting to
interview you.
So we have to be entirely creative to get
our work to the public. Some authors are like
I'm fine with having 3,000
readers. And they're great readers and I don't
want
anymore. But being, you know, small, furry,
hungry
immigrant that's not going to do it for me.
I want the
Times best seller list. So I put in a lot
of work. It
takes about a year or more. Year and a half
to promote a
book. A year to promote in the states, another
half year to promote in Europe and Asia and
other countries. It kills you. And
that year and a half, I could have written
another book in
the meantime. So the dynamics for the writer
has
changed. Now will there be another resurgence
of literature all of a sudden that's somehow
s
based on these platforms? Wow that would be
spectacular.
So far we've seen things in Japan. Japan is
the home of
the cell phone novel written as texts. Huge
best
sellers. I mean hundreds of thousands maybe
millions of
copies sold. High up on the best seller lists
in Japan.
It's basically people writing -- they're usually
love
stories. It's usually a man and a woman texting
each
other back and forth and things fall apart
which is sort
of part of Super Sad True Love Story as well,
but fascinating
stuff. You know are they great works of literature?
Not
by my likes, but maybe I'm just too old to
appreciate it,
you know? But it doesn't read well is the
problem.
>> Male #6: Yeah, that's exactly the thing
I was wondering about.
The only example I've seen are Yelp reviews
by Cormac McCarthy
that are really well done.
[laughter]
>> Female Presenter: It's actually on Yelp?
>> Male #6: They're actually on Yelp for a
lot of places in San
Francisco. And then he reposts them.
>> Gary: Is it really Cormac McCarthy?
>>Female Presenter: It's not like just someone
trolling his zone?
>>Male #6: It's in his style as well. They're
hilarious.
>> Gary: Twitter is going to certify me. They're
going to give
me a badge so you know it's me. Very exciting.
I try to
put some effort into my Facebook posts. Usually
it's
about my dachshund and my twitter posts and
stuff. And Twitter's actually helped me
with the screen play I'm writing. It's 140
characters.
And I'm used to being incredibly verbose.
Soaking in my
own, you know, brilliant verbosity. But Twitter
has made
me actually mind brevity -- think about brevity.
And so,
I don't know. It's okay..
>> Male #6: Cool, thank you.
>> Gary: Thank you.
>> Female #2: Hi. I actually also moved to
the states as a kid and
practiced my accent as well. So I can identify.
>> Gary: Russia?
>>Female #2: I'm from Spain but I also did.
>> Gary: Anya.
>> Female #2: Si. My question is sort of about
the language and
developing the language. I know you mentioned
the
acronym like when JBF and sort of looking
at JK and
going from there. It's such an exaggerated,
kind of an exaggerated evolution of language
that you sort of come up with or
maybe not exaggerated. But just wondering
what your
process was for that. Obviously JK. What did
you come
up to look at that specific.
>> Gary: I wanted to hear how younger people
speak. Teaching
at Columbia is very helpful. You just go out
on the Quad. Everyone is JKing and
whatnot. [laughter] And you know these are
-- these are Columbia University so these
are
Ivy League students. I was at another Ivy
League
campuses where they were discussing my book
and the student
said, "you know? I really identify with Eunice
and the
way she's speaks but I had a lot of trouble
understanding
Lenny because he's just thinking all the time."
It's
like why?
>>Female Presenter: So who does that? [laughter]
>> Gary: So, who does that? So I mean, I was
just at a
panel in key west and William Gibson was speaking
about,
you know, the science fiction writer -- speaking
about
how he captures trends. It really is a process
of
osmosis. You just walk around and you hear
how people
speak. One of the lines in this book was an
old woman
comes out of an old apartment building in
New York and
it's really cold and she says, “oh my God
it's
blustery”. And that really happened. I was
living in this
co-op with all these ancient people. I thought,
blustery. Who the
hell uses that word anymore? You know? It's
almost like
relegated to the extinct vocabulary, because
you know now
it's like, “JBF, it's freezing”. And part
of freezing would
probably be like 4 easing. [laughter]On the
one hand it's like oh
my God I want to protect words like blustery.
On the
other hand, you can't do it because language
evolves. I
don't want to be the person crying big tears
over the
demise of language. There's all kinds of different
persons in countries trying to protect their
languages.
The French Academy always tries to keep English
out. I
don't know if the Spanish Academy does the
same. But
there is one. It's constantly worried about
the purity
of the language, which is a very European
concept trying to protect the purity of th
language whereas
in America it's like “bring it on”. [laughter]
I don't know. I think
it's very hard to keep things the way they
were. And as
a writer who writes about today, I have to
be in tune
with what is happening.
>> Female #2: Just a follow up to that. How
do you then see this
particular book? Besides your other books,
how do you
see this aging or being read in ten years
not only
because whether the things come to pass or
not but in
terms of the language because it's so specific
to now or
ten years from now.
>> Gary: I think about that. Does this book
have an expiration
date. I think all books have an expiration
date, but the
best of them, --and I'm not saying this is
the best of them – but the best do survive
because the concepts are
universal. And I think this is a love story.
And love
changes the way, certain things about love
changes. The
fact that we're texting and tweeting our potential
mates
has changed. But at the same time the actual
biological
feeling is the same. The need for romance,
which is also
a part of the biological neurological aspects.
Reproductive urges. All of that remains pretty
much the
same. Fahrenheit 451 is a great example. The
book is
about -- theoretically it's about a book burning
society,
right? It's about a society that says books
are the
problem and they have to be burned. But when
you read it
closely, it's not really about that; it's
more about people don't want to read books.
The society doesn't have to enforce the book
burning.
There's very few books left. Everyone has
four screens
that they have put on their walls and they're
communicating with those screens all the time.
They
don't have any interior lives. Everything
is led in a
public way. So when Bradbury was writing this
40 years
ago, he's already talking about the present
as we know it
now even though much of the book seems outdated
it
continues to live on in our minds.
>>Male #7: Hey, so having read your work excerpted
in the New
Yorker, you know, effectively becomes short
fiction, but
it's obviously part of a longer novel. And
you know
written as part of the longer novel. Have
you considered
writing something specifically short fiction?
Would you
see that has being kind of a way of addressing
the more
limited time that people have to devote to
books.
>> Gary: This is one of the strangest things
in publishing that
I really can't make heads or tails of. If
people's
attention spans are waning and it's getting
harder and
harder for people to concentrate, wouldn't
you think that
the short story collections and the short
story genre
would profit from this? That there would be
a resurgence? The very opposite has happened.
The sales of short fiction with a few exceptions
--
>> Female Presenter: Kindle singles now like
a whole new genre of shorter.
>> Gary: I don't know what the sales of that
are but the sales
of printed collections -- and they're also
available on
kindle and E book have been plummeting completely.
Good
example of that is Don DeLillo. I mean, Jesus
Christ, Don DeLillo has just published
this amazing collection of short stories that
had not
enjoyed the kind of sales you would except
from a
Don DeLillo novel. I don't know what to make
sense of
that. Why would people not want to read something
much
shorter you know? And I think part of it is
also that
the New Yorker -- you've mentioned the New
Yorker -- they
still do short fiction, but almost every major
outlet in America has
stopped doing it. The Atlantic has now just
one fiction
issue. They crammed it all into one month.
I don't know
how many people read that, but it used to
be -- Atlantic
fiction used to be a major part of the literary
landscape. So
weirdly enough short fiction hasn't benefited
from this. I don't know why.
I think maybe people do still want a novel
because it's a
fully immersive experience. You go into this
whole crazy
world. So in a sense, it's kind of like entering
an interactive World of Warlocks game except
you don't get to shoot anyone.
>> Male #7: Sure. You can obviously do that
in short fiction effectively
as well. And I'm also just curious personally
aside from
commercial reasons, do you have a reason for
preferring
writing novels.
>>Gary: I suck at short stories. I really
do. I can't shut
up. I've written maybe two or three in my
life that have
been published. They're very long. They're
30, 40 pages
long. I just don't know when to stop. Actually
being a
short story writer requires greater skills
I think than being a
novelist because you have to create the entire
world
within the span of 20 pages. I don't have
those skills.
George Saunders does. So if you want to go
read short
satiric fiction that completely explains the
American
condition today go to him. And just buy my
book anyway
and burn it or something.
[laughter]
>> Male #7: Thanks.
>> Male #8: Can I turn it around a little
bit? Because it's sort
of -- yep. You've been saying how it's the
audience's
not reading but my feeling is also it's hard
to find
books that are compelling and they're not
either written
for the 3,000 audience where it's impossible
to plow
through them or they're not written to be
sold in
Wal-Mart. So you know your book was actually
an
exception for me.
>> Gary: Well, thank you. I'm trying to find
that middle ground
between the 3,000 readers and the larger -- and
the
Wal-Mart bin where those products just stack
up and are
moved out etcetera . I wonder, you know, and
I think about
this a lot because I teach at an MFA program
and there
are about 400 MFA programs out there in America.
Well,
English departments can't find students to
learn about
English literature-- American literature.
Creative writing
programs are overflowing. Everybody wants
to write. Do
we create -- and this is the question I always
ask
myself -- do we create a specific kind of
writer, an MFA writer -- somebody who has
a certain approach to literature where, you
know, and MFA
programs all hone the same things characters,
craft etcetera, etcetera. Are we creating
stories that are too similar? I
don't know. It's a good question. If you look
at that
New Yorker 20 under 40 list almost every one
of us has an
MFA. It's very rare for contemporary writers
. In the
old days your MFA was you went to Spanish
civil war and
got your leg shot off and then you wrote about
it. [laughter] Now
you go to Iowa and hang around with 12 other
middle class
people and then you write about that. So it's
quite a
difference. Are we producing a class of people
that are
writing the same thing? Well, looking at that
list of 20
under 40, I would say no. And one of the interesting
things how many of those people on those lists
do come
from foreign countries and are writing about
experiences
that are not within the norm of typical American
background. You have Rivka Galchen who grew
up in Israel among other
places. You have Téa Obreht from Yugoslavia,
the former Yugoslavia.
I think ten out of 20 or something like that
were born
abroad. That's what's so exceptional about
American
literature as opposed to other literatures
the way we do
welcome in people in from – speaking of
short stories, one of the biggest best sellers
in literary fiction
was Jhumpa Lahiri's Interpreter of Maladies.
That sold over a million
copies of short stories about Bengali immigrants
in
Massachusetts. So it's interesting to see.
I think
there is a lot of talent out there. The other
thing is
we're publishing everything that moves. The
publishing
industry is basically throwing darts at a
board hoping something will hit. For a
reader you walk into a store you're surrounded
by
gazillions of books. We're publishing something
like
200,000 books. How do you choose? Except for
things
like the New Yorker or the New York Times
or GoodReads or whatever it is.
It's almost -- there's an embarrassment of
riches. I
almost wish there were fewer writers but they
wrote the
stuff you want. Which is not the Wal-Mart
bin and not
the 3,000 either.
>> Male #8: Right and I hope that you don't
think the answer is
working for HBO, because frankly, it's so
limiting. How
many of these things can be produced in a
year. And
they're driven by, you know, the audience.
>> Gary: Very few. I would say of all the
writers writing -- I
think maybe 2 percent of us will actually
make it into
production. The scripts are commissioned,
but not
necessarily be made. I think if it's good,
it's really
good. I think the Wire explained life in the
American
urban underclass better than any other book
-- it's not
book -- better than any book I've encountered
maybe with
one exception. Random Family, Adriene Nicole
LeBlanc, a woman who graduated from Brown
and spent ten
years living with this south Bronx family.
Other than
that I can't think of any other art form that
has allowed
me to connect with a world which I know nothing
about.
So hats off to the Wire and things like that.
But you're
right for every Wire there's a bunch of shows
that
obviously are sub par.
>> Male #8: I look forward to your next book.
>>Gary: Thank you.
>>Female Presenter: I have one last question.
With all the -- you mention
that the capacity for love has not changed.
But do you
ever think that with all the technology just
these
succinct forms of communication and incomplete
sentences
and thoughts that that's kind of leading to
-- like, a
lack or inability to commit to things?
>> Sure. I mean, I think because we have so
many choices
in every aspect of our lives at this point.
I mean, the
iPhone is a device of choices. I want to walk
to ninth
street. Well, there's four different ways
to get there
and the computer is telling me you can do
it through
route A, route B, route C, route D. The iPhone
doesn't
have any sense of nostalgia. It doesn't remember
that
the first time I kissed someone was along
route B and
that makes a difference. In Super Sad, at
one point, Lenny is trying to
read to Eunice as a way of creating a sense
of communication between them. He's trying
to read Kundera's Unbearable Lightness of
Being. And
she begins to cry because she just doesn't
understand
what he's doing. She doesn't understand what
the value
of this is. She's used to direct communications.
Being
told what to do in a way, either by other
people who are
on the Internet or by the giant corporations
that move
the Internet along. She's unused to the idea
of having a
kind of intellectual, non-pornographic encounter
with
somebody. It's completely new to her. And
the result is
very sad, I think, for both of them. In that
part of the
book it becomes clear this relationship may
not work out.
People say love will find a way. But let's
hope so.
Let's hope there's actual personal encounters.
Physical
encounters for God's sakes and that we don't
just retreat
where it's safest. Because sitting at home
with the
computer is very safe. Sure people can send
-- I always
get angry tweets and Facebookings and e-mails,
you know,
you're such a schmuck. This is a bad hair
day, etcetera. But
it's safer than actually seeing people and
falling in
love with them the old fashioned way.
>>Female Presenter: Okay. Well, thank you
for joining us Gary.
>>Gary: Well, thank-you so much
[Applause]